hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
what's your name
Sally who toy story comes out soon yeah
yeah there are two clips that have been
released online one came out today
called get him and another one called
meet alright let's go watch let's check
this out Oh before I do I wanted to say
thank you to everyone who's download a
false in the Stardust app over there
buddy 30-second reactions reviews for a
new film TV show and or trailer some of
them are micro sketches we post daily
whole thing is free to download whole
thing is free to use I like free stuff
do you like free stuff Sally what else
is free subscribing mmm to do that so
subscribe to Sally's channel yeah let's
start with meat for he since that is the
oldest weird body made a friend in class
[Music]
that seems like it's really working on
you I a little bit trepidatious about
this movie slightly
I thought the trilogy was perfect yeah I
thought the trilogy was perfect well if
there's an argument to be made that most
movies are essentially cash grabs
because every movie wants to profit
every movie wants to make money I've
still haven't seen anything from this I
think the word necessary sequel gets
thrown around a little too often cuz
what sequel usually is necessary
I'm just haven't felt the Toy Story or
Pixar spark from this this looks funny
this looks amusing forky looks very
adorable
I actually liked how it in for his
introduction how it looks like a little
like a twisted experiment like a
Frankenstein monster
I like that so far everything else
you've seen seems like pretty familiar
um we're them a little more interesting
to working from watching these two clips
because I'm going we gonna learn some
rules about what makes a toy become the
life I know that the trilogy was like
perfect and the third movie just killed
records I mean it was insane how much
press it got because so many people
loved it when I first heard they were
doing a fourth one I wasn't happy about
it but then when I found out woody in
the first movie is really into Bo Peep
and then she just kind of disappeared
and it was never explained true and so
that was the only reason why I was
really excited about the fourth one was
that it was all about Bo Peep and she
was like kind of a badass and I'm like
I'm ready for that but yeah all the
clips you know they're just kind of the
random fun characters that they have in
each movie like the key and Peele
characters here
well that's amusing it's a door I'm sure
this movie is gonna be fun I'm sure I'm
gonna like this movie hell I might even
love this movie but you know like
there's the Monsters Inc which is
special and amazing and then there's
monsters University which is like it's
good you don't I don't think it's as
like special no like finding Nemo is
great whatever that they waited until
all the kids were in college that had
grown up with the Monsters Inc movie and
then did the college version when we
were all in college that movie came out
with new freshmen look at the marketing
producer what sally's minds it's just it
was brilliant the concept of but I get
what you mean the movie itself wasn't
like super special as a boat like it
stills it was still really good animated
better than most other companies that do
animations Pixar still product through
clever quality but it wasn't like as
special like finding Nemo special and
amazing and then there's finding dory
you want my theory on this they're all
gonna die by the no no they change if
you've ever been to California Adventure
at Disneyland in California California
Adventure they have this huge carnival
pier a long time ago they made the
decision to change it to Pixar pier so
they had all these like carnival rides
and all the stuff so my theory was that
this movie is gonna be carnival theme
and then everything about the Pixar pier
is gonna make sense and they're gonna
have like the whole like all these words
that you see will be what you can like
win like the car so you think this is
just a big commercial probably I mean
Disney's clever they know how to like we
have everything planned out so far in
advance that things look like they like
fell into place when really they like
planned it all okay yeah every toy story
movie feels special it's like it's not
like the first one special and the rest
are just cash grabs I kind of hold the
Toy Story franchise maybe perhaps people
might feel like this is a little unfair
to sort of a higher standard I expect to
be very moved yeah I expect to laugh
like hysterically you know haha and then
also Bali you know I expect to feel all
those emotions because of the standard
each installment has left me with to me
I'd this quarter just feels like like
it's still adorable this still looks
great for he looks appealing but also
John Laster now isn't a part of Pixar
and he was the creator of like the first
Toy Story like Toy Story was the first
Pixar movie ever why they fired him
because he had too many good ideas is
that what it was I hear he's a great
human well I think the next stage is to
make your live-action Toy Story film do
it with motion toys for the mark hamill
Chucky that's coming out they've been
taking Toy Story characters as the promo
whoa in the posters I think it's
brilliant that when they're releasing
the clips of Toy Story there have been
yeah posters what I want to see is a
spin-off live-action of Sid grown-up
psychologically traumatized from the
experience how no one has believed him
about these toys he's portrayed as a
bully but he's not really a bully he's
just a kid
messing around with toys but he's
portrayed as
this evil thing and then these toys just
completely traumatize him I know he's
like a garbage man in Toy Story 3 is
like a little cameo or something that's
the reason why like Toy Story is the
reason why as a kid I was there find of
my joys cuz of that scene like I thought
it was like a horror movie as exactly so
I think Disney should make a one-off
spin-off Sid having to go to create it
isn't in this movie I don't think
there's a point like closure yeah
closure first city he deserves it man
these heroes of ours have put them
through the wringer imagine ease of
working at like the carnival Laney turns
around sees woody and just the toys are
just put him in this this crazy isolated
situation no one's gonna believe it
except to go three years of
psychotherapy and medication for
hallucinations hey are you excited for
Toy Story 4 keep a look out for our
review if anyone knows I'm the kind of
guy to be honest if I think something's
gonna be bad or whatever that I walk
like a lad and I was like I'm about this
and then I'm really liking that movie a
lot and I'm hoping this is the case I
almost I think I'm watching it next week
actually at an early screening jealous
you should be I would offer you an extra
pass but I don't have an extra passed I
invited six other friends all right
hey let's give a nerd a shout out here
let's give a page from the day shout to
a woman named Victoria Hundley beautiful
woman who lives all the way in the UK so
here's the situation that happened
she had pledged part of the reward here
to get a shout out accidentally missed
her one month she messaged me and I was
like I'm sorry I messed up so we gave
her to shoutouts last month to make up
for the month that we missed and now I
haven't heard from her like a month and
a half I'm pretty sure she's mad at me
I mean she's resentful like even though
I try making up with to shout outs and
month that's a rare thing for Gregg to
do for someone I think she's like oh
he's stupid you're stupid Gregg young
you're ugly
so like Victoria please no or don't
forgive you you [ __ ] oh yeah that's
what she sounds like
I've heard many recordings summer I'm
really good at impressions and axes we
started out I was like I don't think
she's Australian no Australian sound she
sounds sweet old Jimmy oh we're all will
hairy poor and that's Victoria honey
there's your shoutout Victoria I haven't
I hope I don't know what you're so I
thought you were gonna get married like
six months ago why have you gotten
married yet were those weddings why she
mad at her fiance why we go marry yet so
she says she does that face too
well was she a married she liked this
video hit the like notification bells oh
yeah subscribe to the new John John
looks great and I'm happy for John to
shop here